foreign
[Music]
but I won't show it no I'll just hold my
breath and keep it quiet
every little earthquakes
[Music]
[Applause]
I try my besties
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
every little earthquake
[Music]
only makes me stronger
[Applause]
[Music]
every little earthquake
foreign
new location in DC that I did not know
existed until I found it and by
coincidence it also just happens to be
close to a Metro track who knew anyhow I
just want to put out a quick thank you
to ultra POI for sponsoring this video
and giving me a reason to go out and
explore all these different parts of DC
if you'd like to grab a set of those orb
POI Pro that I was spending in this
video you can do so at a discount by
using the promo code drexfactor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout over at
ultrapoi.com that gets you a discount on
any set of poi in their store and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thank you once again to ultra POI for
sponsoring me and by flow
and speaking of thank yous uh big thanks
go out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
boy all of these companies have helped
out to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible you
should learn more about them you can
find links to learn about all these
different companies down in the
description
um and of course big thanks to the
non-business friend of the channel That
is Becca beckonen uh thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission uh finally this video
would not be possible we're not for the
kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons they and the people listed down
in the description helped to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently
supported but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access so a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to check out more of my flow videos
I will include links to those down in
the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today for yourself
and I'll see you with a brand new video
real soon take care now
peace